it's been called an environmental
catastrophe of unprecedented scale
tons of dead fish washing up in the
river oda between germany and poland
poisoned by a so far mystery pollutant
which has contaminated the water
the most important thing is to find out
what is the cause and also
to remove as soon as possible
the dead fish and other organisms from
the river because
fish is
been eaten by
by birds by
other animals this is a really
a huge
task a huge challenge
volunteers have already collected more
than 10 tons of dead fish
so far mercury poisoning has been ruled
out
but tests are continuing after
unnaturally high salt levels were
detected
a mass die-off like this should be
flagged quickly
and polish officials have been
criticized for being too slow to tell
their german neighbours as the
contaminations spread
parts of the river are now so toxic
people have been told not to fish or
swim
the local fishermen are particularly
affected for them it is existential only
time will tell what effects this will
have over the next few years on the
other hand this is also catastrophic for
the tourism industry a good tourist
infrastructure has just developed here
on the oda
poland has offered a reward for catching
anyone found responsible for dumping
chemical waste into the river
but extensive damage has already been
done
with warnings the cleanup could take
years
siobhan robbins sky news